i'm allison williams Daniel Neil and
this is the last thing on my phone and
his fun Renato my hairstylist took it
I'm still learning how to be blonde it's
not natural a screen grab of dear white
people and how many people disliked it
eighty six thousand people I shouldn't
be saying about it oh my god
I have everything really close to each
other so I'd like to 55 and 256 a.m. I
don't know why 503 and 505 I am 737 you
know you got the idea and then to BM it
was on a perfect day in my opinion mine
is kind of like every single like time
oh my god wait what did you sit there
and do this I like to nap but my mom
sends me so many flipping videos mom oh
my god is an African one yes I haven't
seen in penis I thought I should don't
know what that is it's three minutes
long religious you look whom this is
mine which is a behind-the-scenes shoot
for the cover with the moxie stop by
look I'm pretty she is and then she's
gone from it that's boring last one from
the Hollywood rapport yeah my last one
is from Volcom a timeless wedding in
Fairfield Connecticut now I'm just
sucked into this bogey mo Oh mine are so
basic the double hearts the fire and the
broken heart that's probably cuz girls
is wrapping pizza is not far behind
neveress yeah so mine's the laughing
face the Khalid key mm-hmm
and then just half of the bottles of
champagne because that's how we roll out
here all right easy posting tomorrow
[Music]